On March 5th, 2022, Russian gymnast Ivan Kuliak
stepped on the podium
at the International Gymnastics
Federation World Cup in Doha, Qatar.
He won the bronze medal in the parallel bars.
Next to him was Illia Kovtun, the
gold medal winner from Ukraine
and silver medalist Milad
Karimi, representing Kazahstan.
The situation was already tense.
Russia’s invasion of Ukraine had
begun just nine days earlier.
And Kuliak decided to show his support for the
war, by attaching this symbol to his uniform:
three pieces of white tape, forming the letter Z.
By that time, the Z was
becoming an obsession in Russia.
And a controversial symbol worldwide
as the new way to signal approval for the war
and loyalty to Russian President Vladimir Putin.
Since the invasion began in late February, the Z
has shown up on billboards in St. Petersburg...
T-shirt stands in Moscow...
Auto rallys...
And flash mobs created for social media.
There’s even this photo – posted on the
website of a children’s cancer hospice
showing sick children organized into
the shape, outside, in the snow.
The letter has been used to vandalize
the homes of Russians who oppose the war
and is now banned from public
display in several countries.
So how did this symbol become shorthand
for supporting Russian aggression?
The letter Z was first
spotted in late February 2022
on Russian military equipment
gathering at Ukraine’s border.
Along with other painted
white markings, like V and O.
At first, what these symbols meant was unclear
Z isn’t part of the Cyrillic Alphabet –
the writing system used in Russia and Ukraine.
The Z sound in Cyrillic is
written sort of like a 3.
And “V” looks like the Latin letter “B.”
But once the invasion began, most analysts
agreed the markings were for tactical purposes
likely to prevent confusion on the battlefield.
And potentially denoting where
specific forces were attacking from.
The Russian military didn’t
explain what the markings meant.
Until intrigue around them grew online
and people in Russia saw the chance
to use the Z as a tool for propaganda.
One of the most common ways that theletter Z
is being given meaning inRussian
is by latinizing it in theRussian word
"Za" which means for.
And in incorporating it into slogans like
[speaking in Russian] For victory.
[speaking in Russian] For the president.
[speaking in Russian] For the boys.
So there was an attempt to fill it.
That's Aglaya Snetkov.
She's a lecturer on Russian foreign, security,
and domestic policy at University College London.
You increasingly have pictures
which are so absurdly staged.
It's obviously fake, butit sort of
doesn't matter.
So the pictures of the kids, for
example, who can't even read or write
they obviously have no idea what the Z
they're holding means or anything like that.
But it sort of almost doesn't matter
so long as you throw it out there.
Click on these slogans’ hashtags,
like “for russia” and “for peace”
and you’ll find tens of thousands
of posts on Instagram alone.
Many of them originating from
the Russian Ministry of Defense.
The political technologists in Russia, in Kremlin,
and in and around the Ministry of Defense
have decided to jump on the opportunity
and reinfuse the meaning of
those obscure symbols.
Kiril Avramov teaches classes on Russian
and Soviet symbolism and propaganda
at the University of Texas, Austin.
Avramov told me the point of
these memes is to turn the Z
and sometimes the V into something cool.
He translated a few of them.
Is like street slang for "for the boys".
"Power is in truth." Which is actually
a quote from a post-Soviet blockbuster.
They're picking already familiar slogans to
post-Soviet Russians and putting into those visuals
and then recreating those in flash mobs...
graffiti...
and all the way to the
presidential administration.
One strategy for turning Z into
a patriotic propaganda icon
has been connecting it to
Russian glory of the past
in particular, the Soviet
victory in World War II.
The Soviet Union suffered devastating losses
defending itself against invasion by Nazi Germany.
But they were ultimately victorious,
with the Red Army fighting its way
back to Berlin and defeating Hitler,
establishing the Soviet
Union as a world superpower.
The “Great Patriotic War” is still a potent
symbol of heroism and glory in Russia.
And is honored each year on May 9th, or “Victory
Day” - the anniversary of Germany’s capitulation.
With massive demonstrations
of modern military might
and remembrance of ancestors
who were killed in the war.
The historical trauma is immense in Soviet times.
There was a huge sacrifice on
the part of the Soviet people.
And those are some highly symbolic events.
This ever-present historical awareness makes
World War II imagery a direct link to patriotism,
and presents the opportunity to
connect the nostalgia of Soviet heroism
with Russia’s current attacks on Ukraine.
Take this meme posted to the Russian
Ministry of Defense’s Instagram
on March 4, 2022, which as of
early April has over 21,000 likes.
It shows a “Z” superimposed over a black and
white photo of Soviet soldiers on one side...
and a photo of modern Russian soldiers
looking back on the other side.
The hashtag says “heroes".
The photo on the left is a famous image from
the original Moscow Victory Parade of 1945
celebrating Germany’s surrender.
It’s still the largest paradeever held
in Moscow’s Red Square
organizedby Soviet dictator Joseph Stalin.
The image shows Soviet soldiers carrying captured
Nazi flags and banners before destroying them
and has been used in Soviet and post-Soviet
patriotic propaganda ever since.
So every Russian and Soviet person
would recognize that immediately.
The “Z” is paired with the slogan
“za pobedu” - “for victory”
and is styled in black and orange stripes.
Which, other than plain white, is the
most common way the Z is displayed.
The pattern represents the color
scheme of the Ribbon of St. George
one of Putin’s favorite propaganda symbols.
Its origins trace back through
hundreds of years of Russian history
as a symbol of military glory.
At the end of World War II, Stalin
used the ribbon on a medal awarded
to all Soviets who served in
the war – including civilians.
The ribbon, which everyone knows is, you
know, if you see it it's the Russian military
might and its a signifier that you're Russian.
The ribbon of St. George is now handed
out every year ahead of Victory Day
and is a central emblem of the celebrations.
Invoking the memory of glorious past in
order to play this propaganda trick, right?
Equating this war with this one, in
terms of justness and legitimacy.
Beyond emerging as the new
mark of loyalty to Putin
the Z doesn’t hold any individual meaning.
And that seems to be part
of the strategy behind it.
And that, I think, shows the way
in which Putin's propaganda works,
He throws things out there, sees
what lands, and then goes with that.
The symbol just became
recognizable, the explanations
which I call "post rationalization" is that this
is all planned, what the Zs and the Vs stand for.
For victory. For Zelenskyy. Or you name it.
The advancement of so many
alternative explanations actually adds energy
to the state propaganda.
Whether or not any of these
explanations end up sticking,
the Z’s evolution
from tanks and trucks...
to memes...
then flash mobs around Russia...
to pro-Putin demonstrations around the world...
shows that as a symbol’s visibility grows,
so does its power as a tool for propaganda.